are in
the I moved to the US just before my
7eventh birthday before that I lived in
Mexico with my mom my older brother and
at the time my baby brother my dad would
travel back and forth and send us money
but we were very poor we lived in a Tiny
Town in the middle of the desert where
most people did not have running water
and things like blenders and
refrigerators were for quote rich people
when my dad finally saved enough money
so that we could all move to the US it
took every penny we had for about a
month my mom my older brother and I
shared one plate of food while my mom
breastfed the baby I had only one shirt
so that meant that every time my mom
washed it she would place a trash bag
over me to cover me but as a child I
thought this was funny but when I moved
to the US it was obvious that I was
different I looked different I spoke a
different language and I alternated
between the same shirts and wore the
same sweater every day to school which
was clearly not the norm here in the USA
only one other girl spoke Spanish in my
class and let's just say she did not
want to be my friend needless to say I
felt lonely and I was bullied but the
thing that really crushed me was that I
also felt lonely at home I now lived in
the USA with my dad but in a broken
marriage where yelling and slamming of
tables is a frequent ordeal Life as a
child felt like hell I often cried
myself to sleep at night but only after
waiting for my younger siblings to fall
asleep so that they wouldn't see or hear
me cry I constantly questioned my
existence and what the point of my life
was before I was even a teenager despite
all that I was actually quite smart and
I learned English very quickly and I
soon became a straight day student but I
felt frustrated with myself because I
seemed like I could never get my parents
to see me to truly see me I grew up
feeling empty and as a teenager once I
got my first job I immediately began a
downhill turn developing shopping habits
that would maybe hopefully give me that
feeling of selfworth and love that I
craved I bought assortments of makeup
and dresses and shoes and purses so that
I'd never have to repeat an outfit I
didn't realize I was trying to fill a
void you see shopping was fun and after
all I did shop the clearance section and
shop at the thrift store so I was being
a smart Shopper and getting the deals
when my husband and I got married we
rented a three bed two bath home and I'm
ashamed to say I had clothes in every
closet every one of those three closets
he had about half of one closet and the
rest was pretty much mine not to mention
the countless shoes that lined our Kings
SI bed as a newlywed I worked as a nurse
working 3 to 4 days a week and my
husband was gone all day during the week
so you bet I was out enjoying my
favorite hobby shopping only now I
wasn't just shopping for clothes because
you see I needed home decor I mean I had
to make the rental seem cozy to this day
after our 7 years of marriage I'm still
in love with my husband and we've always
been cheesy lovers but we had our issues
to work out when we first got married
clearly I had a shopping addiction and
he had a video game addiction I would
often arrive for my 12-hour shifts at
the hospital to find him sitting down
playing games this wouldn't have been a
problem except he wouldn't get up to
greet me and often wouldn't even turn
his head from the screen in order to say
hello as a newlywed this left me with an
intense feeling of loneliness to eat
dinner alone go to sleep alone and spend
my days alone so I again masked the
loneliness with my hobby shopping I
didn't like being alone it made me feel
uncomfortable because I didn't like the
girl in the mirror I didn't want to
spend time with her
I told myself that she was ugly she was
unworthy she was a waste of time and so
I looked for distractions to quiet that
voice until one day everything changed I
met a travel nurse at my previous job to
whom I will always be thankful for
having gifted me with the book The Total
Money Makeover by Dave Ramsey I'm sure
if it had just been a recommendation I
would have never bothered to get it for
myself but since it was a gift I read it
and I read it to my husband and it
completely changed changed our lives for
the first time in our lives we
considered the idea that we didn't have
to live in debt that we could be rich
and that we could impact more lives if
we were Rich that it wasn't a sin to be
rich and in fact the path that we were
headed down wasn't exactly making us the
best human beings to begin with before
reading this book I'd never imagined
myself living a life of wealth but
needless to say we were hooked we made
plans to get out of debt we worked
overtime almost every every single week
my husband sold his video games we sold
our TV we sold so many of our
possessions and this is when the
decluttering began all of a sudden I
began to ask myself questions that I had
never asked before like what do I value
what do I want out of life what clothes
actually make me feel good and do I
really need this I began decluttering my
belongings and in the process I began
peeling away layers of a mask that I had
placed over myself I remember the day
that I got rid of my real human hair
extensions a girl who had hair to or
waist but just wanted volume I felt an
intense sense of guilt at the money that
I had spent for this and for having
failed to consider the woman that gave
up her own hair to feed my vanity it's
now been 5 years since I began
decluttering and I hate to admit it but
it was a very slow process for me in the
very beginning but in so many ways I'm
thankful that it happened this way
because it was never about the stuff it
was about about letting go of my desire
to please others about accepting myself
loving myself about finding a cause
greater than my own and reducing my
NeverEnding desire for more perhaps you
expected me to say that I am now a
millionaire and I'm definitely not but I
do consider myself Rich because
minimalism has allowed me to slowly
release and let go of not only physical
possessions but the very things that
were holding me back from healing as I
painstakingly removed bag after bag of
physical excess I also removed emotional
baggage for the first time in my life I
faced the girl in the mirror and I
smiled at her with love I forgave her
for the mistakes that she was ashamed of
she forgave those who hurt her and more
importantly I was proud of her and
without even realizing it because I put
so much time and energy into removing
clutter I no longer had the desire to
bring it all back in and because
decluttering was often such an
emotionally draining task and selling
and donating items took time I became a
much more intentional Shopper and my
desire for more began to diminish
likewise my vision of what wealth means
also changed I will forever be grateful
that I got to work as a hospice nurse
because constantly working with patients
who were dying has been my biggest
motivator to live to sa her life to take
advantage of my time and make a
difference and then also to have hobbies
and enjoy doing nothing without feeling
guilt
after these 5 years of pursuing slow
simple living we've now reduced our
expenses to mainly our Essentials this
has allowed me to quit my college career
eliminating our only stable income
source to be clear I'm very thankful for
the money generated from this YouTube
channel but $13 to $15 a month does not
pay the bills I'm now a homeschool mom
and I've never been happier and this
wouldn't have been possible had we
continued down the path of our shopping
and media addictions I now get to guide
my children according to my values I get
to be a support to my husband which
makes him happier and I have time for
myself to be able to devote to my
hobbies and take care of myself which
makes me happier which makes our whole
family much happier this is not to say
that we don't have problems everyone
does and if you don't right now you will
but I now know my values I know what is
essential to me and I try to live a life
that aligns with that to me purposefully
living a life that LS with your values
that's true wealth as a home hospice
nurse I visited rundown trailers as well
as Mansions but in the end neither the
rich nor the poor can escape the reality
of death I've seen grief and regret but
I've also seen peace at a life well
lived I know that my life will end and I
know what I want when the day comes I
know what I would love to accomplish but
even if that never happens I'm enjoying
the journey to me wealth isn't some
number some goal you finally obtained
some achievement you finally
accomplished it's more than that and
it's inside of you minimalism for me has
been a tool that allowed me to find what
I truly value in life when I couldn't
see it because it was hidden beneath all
my clutter decluttering did so much more
for me than give my home a pretty
aesthetic by removing the physical
excess in my life I gain time for the
things that truly matter to me and to me
this is everything thank you so much for
watching my minimalism journey and I
hope that it's encouraging to you in
your pursuit of living a more fulfilled
slower paced life if you enjoyed this
video you'd love my video is a college
education necessary where I share my
dad's poverty to richest story I'll
leave it here so that you can watch it
next and if you haven't read The Total
Money Makeover I highly recommend it you
may be able to access it for free
through your library and apps like
hoopla or Libby but I do also have an
affiliate link for audible where you can
get a free 30-day trial of audible with
a free Audi book yours to keep even if
you cancel I'll leave the link down in
the description box below if you like
this video please give it a thumbs up
and help support my channel and don't
forget to subscribe so you won't miss
when I post a new video until next time
bye for now